crash bandicoot it's just like Dark Soul
guys just can't stop can you everything
is the Dark Souls oh the game it's a
little difficult and it's just like Dark
Soul
this monster energy drink I just like
dark soul oh the game is a little hard
Ruby hmm but let me tell you what this
game is easy there oDesk baby number one
likes player on you to bet that's to me
I've never died a single time in any
video game ever and I'm here to prove to
you how easy this game is you crybaby
son of a [ __ ] here we go the game is
more hard it must spin back Dark Souls
oh my god it's got boxes just like Dark
Souls Wow good imagery this is actually
pretty nostalgic I don't know about you
guys I never played the first crash
I played the second and the third night
I played them with my mom she would
always she would always just get a bunch
of life for me so I could beat the
bosses I mean this is just like started
school wow it's so hard it's really
difficult
honestly I must be incredibly lucky to
not have died yet it really feels truly
incredible
oh [ __ ] get [ __ ] turtle
oh look at that is that the end of the
level zero [ __ ] death baby easy boom
yeah hazy perfect baby
did you just bomb it that out okay
there are deaths baby [ __ ] the boxes
okay [ __ ] them oh look at that just like
Dark Souls perfect thank you
oh look at that another zero day oh it's
almost like this game isn't hard at all
this is so weird
okay so it's a boss fight coming up
maybe I spoke too soon because the dark
could Dark Souls is famous for having
brutally difficult boss fight this fight
oh god what is he possibly going to do
that was pretty much impossible to judge
I guess I have to learn his movesets or
something Wow
this is pretty much impossible again I
like Wow incredible I get it now
whoa there Rowe death baby hell yeah man
oh my god you guys this is exactly like
that one part in Dark Soul this is
exactly like Disney Fantasia to be fair
this is pretty difficult
like you need lightning reflexes you
need to be practically on drugs to play
this dying is for [ __ ] and dead
people and I'm not one of them all right
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is that
[ __ ] cancerous piece of [ __ ] game
what the [ __ ]
when do I jump
jump but the [ __ ] is wrong with this
[ __ ] thing jump what's this [ __ ]
wrong name when do I jump what do I need
a peg in here anyway [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's so easy to tell on those
whatever what is this [ __ ] shape
what's the hell okay how about I don't
jump cuz I know everyone's like you have
to not jump on that one it's the game
glitch like I can't get over it
I can't get over it look how easy those
are why is this one impossible it makes
no [ __ ] sense it makes no [ __ ]
sense what the [ __ ] okay sure sure
sure look there let's all the sudden
throw in an impossible jump in the game
yeah that does that make sense that's
cool let me get over this [ __ ] thing
what is that I don't get it the jump is
impossible
they're like a boost button I don't get
it
oh yes [ __ ] you it is possible it is
possible to do the jump what the hell it
was super easy can you [ __ ] off I said
what a heavy business jackpot
this is not funny anymore like I legit
just want to move on please come upon it
if is a block weak you jump over a
[ __ ] dentist board with a board
dark souls
thank you thank you [ __ ] off
eat a dick hope you die of particular
10g it's on turn on the fan it's so
[ __ ] hard
I have dared that that level does not
[ __ ] count okay
it is not count this game is easy please
stop just stop stop stop let me go like
a doctor okay now we're back to the
regular platforming which is the easiest
of the easy by the [ __ ] the [ __ ] is he
anyway like a raccoon squirrel frog what
is what it's like just Oh what you want
with all free life thank you kind sir
thank you [ __ ] oh wow that was really
that was out tough one oh not the
flowers okay give me my [ __ ] mind
back shaking dear bro
best baby if you don't have 0 death in
all games ever then don't even talk to
me
alright don't even bother speak just go
[ __ ]
when does this game get hard again
curious let me know if you know whatever
okay the game gives you extra things if
you [ __ ] up just like Dark Souls but
what's that [ __ ] were you going uh-huh
whatever it doesn't count if I die okay
doesn't count
well if you think I get bigger with that
come on
oh not today
z not today no thank you thank you bye
easy the sixth level [ __ ] ever end
Jesus Christ my God thank you
well as this this has again hey look at
that look at that a new area does it get
hard now that's a [ __ ] that yeah [ __ ]
yes feed run this [ __ ]
kids never played 3d platformers before
is that the problem but actually Super
Mario okay that's why I have a news
action
y'all never never play Christ shame
shameful place where I play bug sold I
got to the first part and then I walked
off man this little raccoon game too
hard [ __ ] you are for me man
welcome back yes better the town all
right stop
they wrote that all right oh man I love
playing Sims 4 it's just my Dark Soul I
love decorating the house not today
Marty son of a [ __ ] that's right give
me my checkpoint stage daddy
I'm an endeavor the [ __ ] official
must kill me I'd say almost because I
can't die
this [ __ ] what what I do
well what's the point of that do these
come back
why stay hidden pass over there what the
[ __ ] where am I
y'all better go back to playing candy
crush all right if you think this game
is hard you clearly never played a [ __ ]
you can make hey Mae talk to you [ __ ]
[ __ ] flower what I never liked them
anyway
okay no one likes a plane if you're a
point [ __ ] unsubscribe from this
video I mean I'm not kidding you it
discriminating your client now yeah
that's right what you going to [ __ ] you
think I'm gonna mix the Box think again
flower loving [ __ ] you change thing boom
and now I [ __ ] my [ __ ] why does he keep
feeling her I don't get it she's ugly
that's right I said it just like Dark
Soul oh it's another box okay oh well
this should be difficult [ __ ]
[ __ ] how do I know where he's gonna jump
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] your boss sucks
and why is this what kind of raccoon
can't even swim meet the box-t week's
crew could you not tell does it have
enough [ __ ] tail I don't know
[ __ ] you're getting [ __ ] now what you
gonna do what you gonna do son
Oh No Oh what the [ __ ] I got fun get
[ __ ] get box get he thought anyway using
JEP them guess I'm good
just get on back we've got down hey guys
courteously we're going to play a boss
that it's completely [ __ ] random and
you take no skill at all you just got to
get lucky and that's a pretty good game
it's almost just like dorks okay
although I am I quit YouTube oh oh oh
[ __ ] I jump on you I jump on you on
purpose
I'm a neighbor of victims yeah with that
just [ __ ] die please
great great just great just great just
[ __ ] great just great
this game is great I'm having a great
time this is just what I want sex is
what I need huh playing that game with
its [ __ ] people [ __ ] broken asking
what's that [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
no but this you see the reason why
you're the crash is the new pressures
harder because I suck at games now oh oh
hey many model time get out of my space
at [ __ ] Ripper poo okay alright
alright
rough start rough start and
[Music]
if you're tuning in right now basically
having died a single time yet I'm an MLG
player pro I don't know if that's even a
thing anymore
basically I can't die I'm untouchable
I've been battling this boss for the
last 20 minutes and it's not because
I've been dying it's because I just an
epic battle that never seems to think
then for some reason but I have not died
yet and as you can see here it's going
great everything is going skipper what I
say general Jeff barrel just nod in your
bladder dad hello fine
why did I say you know I don't even feel
like celebrating cuz I was my god that
was easy
that was a da ah ah oh so easy you know
I actually realized that Dark Souls and
Crash Bandicoot are the same because
they're both so me
[Music]
leave a like for if you think Crash
Bandicoot is a raccoon leave a like if
you think he's a fox leave a like if you
think he's a video game character
my name is say awesome scissors easy
easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy
Hey ha ha back back and that said duck
Manama Sai Baba